on average america's 400 wealthiest
people are 40 richer than a year ago of
the 345 people who returned to the
forbes 400 in 2021
314 of them are now wealthier
surging tech stocks and an ipo boom are
largely responsible for the boost the
fortunes of the 10 biggest gainers
increased an average of 222
here's a look at the top five at number
five is bobby murphy of snapchat with a
net worth of 15.2 billion dollars that's
a 223 percent increase from last year
that's 10.5 billion dollars murphy has
been investing his fortune in california
real estate buying a number of upscale
properties in the southern part of the
state in recent years at number four is
joe gabia of airbnb with a net worth of
10.8 billion dollars his fortune went up
that's 7.7 billion dollars from last
year the co-founder and chief product
officer plays a behind-the-scenes role
at the company but his philanthropy has
made headlines
he donated 25 million dollars to help
deal with san francisco's massive
homelessness problem and helped launch
airbnb.org
a non-profit which pays airbnb hosts to
shelter refugees
at number three is vinod khosla with a
net worth of 8.6 billion dollars
the venture capitalist fortune went up
that's 6.2 billion dollars from last
year
this was thanks to stakes in several
successful ipos including affirm and
doordash as well as a new estimate of
his stake in alphabet cosa also owns
positions in square and instacart both
of which grew during the pandemic number
two is airbnb ceo brian chesky with a
net worth of 12.5 billion dollars this
is up 303
that's 9.4 billion dollars from last
year chesky described the beginning of
the pandemic as the most difficult
period in his life but things are
turning around the company is recovering
and he's spoken recently about airbnb's
intent on capitalizing on the travel
revolution currently underway
finally at number one is dan gilbert of
rocket companies with a net worth of
30.9 billion dollars
this is up 312
that's 23.4 billion dollars since last
year gilbert's fortune mostly comes from
rocket companies shares but he's also
received a boost from his online sneaker
sale platform stockx the sneaker
marketplace completed a fundraising
round in april at a 3.8 billion dollar
valuation
you